dear kitten you've probably noticed that
there's a new thing in the house it is
called a dog and I know this because
before you I had a best friend named
peanut rest in peace
at first I assumed peanut was just a
very ugly cat charming in his own way
but terrible breath awful
so kitten here are some things that you
need to know
dear kitten imagine a cat now take away
independence cleanliness and
intelligence what you have left is
basically a dog here's an example
yesterday I saw the dog sitting on his
butt scooching forward with his front
paws and he looked over at me and you
know what he said he said check it out
I'm walking on two legs just like the
peoples do I mean it gives you an idea
of what we're dealing with here dear
kitten you might see me get a little
ninja crazytown now and then you know
like don't get freaked out I'm just
expressing dominance which is oh my no
you are not good at that that was
actually worse it looked like your spine
just sneezed no boy dear kitten
you might hear the phrase but dog is a
man's best friend that is frankly
incredible marketing on their part I
don't know how they did it they're
certainly not buying ads in the
newspaper and have you seen what they do
with newspapers trust me it's the
opposite of reading if you know what I
mean I mean they poop on them dear
kitten the dog is the sort of creature
then we'll decide whether it should put
something in its mouth by putting it in
its mouth that's the level of decision
making that goes on they basically eat
everything
case in point but paper they even eat
those weird brown dehydrated packets
that the humans give us don't get mad
let the dog eat all of our dry food if
it gets caught it gets put in jail and
right then we can enjoy the moist
deliciousness of the can without
interruption
it's a gambit dear kitten you may hear
the dog being referred to as a pop AAA
which i think is some sort of a French
Way of saying puppet this explains why
they attach that string to him from time
to time
worst marionette ever if you ask me but
the point is if they try to put that
string on you just freeze you don't want
to get into show business trust me dear
kitten yes the dog can be cuddly at
times I mean just today came over and he
started licking the inside of my ears
was it weird yes but also rather
pleasant don't judge
when they get happy stay to the front
because their tails become some sort of
a weird psycho furry sword and I've seen
them take the legs right out from under
a baby deer kitten our lives just got a
bit more difficult and the lone time
will be harder to find but at least we
can rest assured that the humans won't
get too lonely during our naps and
perhaps that is enough that's right
doggy bow down